I am 30. 30 years old do you have any
children I have two and I also have
custody of my niece okay okay so three
kids live with you yep
okay how old are your kids
um thirteen three and then my niece is
nine thirteen three and nine thirteen
your your children do they have the same
dad no
was you ever married no why are you not
with the three-year-old dad
oh so we have the same birthday and you
look at us I hope it's not my Wi-Fi I
think no girl I apologize I think it's
mine okay all right so let's try it
again so why are you not with a
three-year-old dad
um I'd be totally honest and transparent
so my youngest daughter is a one-night
stand baby
we co-parent well
we just didn't take it anywhere
afterward after the one night stand
um
yeah like y'all don't wear condoms in
one night stands
I mean I can explain to you the story if
you wanna hear it okay so I was in a
relationship with a guy for seven years
that was my longest relationship
um we broke up and I let loose and yeah
I definitely should have used protection
but it was my birthday it was his
birthday we was drunk
and yeah we made a baby
yeah that's hilarious yeah what do we
think of
um that broken women
broken Society oh wait also one thing
one quick thing guys we're turning the
chat onto members only so become a
member if you want to be a part of the
chat anyways go ahead
um these women like this one night stand
babies because it was her birthday are
raising the Next Generation
and and and I'm sure women like that are
not an isolated case there are many
women like that specifically in America
um where there are children being raised
by women who are so frivolous with their
vaginas let's say right that they give
it to any and everyone and now they've
got children to race because of it what
do you think of that
frivolous Willies too
yeah but but like I said women decide
who they have children with we spoke
about it already it's the woman that are
deciding to have these children because
there's a big risk for them it's a big
whenever it's a bigger risk for you you
have to exercise more risk management
because you're the one who could end up
in a much more negative situation well
and we have and we have more options
when it comes to preventing that sort of
stuff than men do
I feel like that the story I feel like
the story of that was
probably not representing a large number
of women
and remember her child is not
represented in a large number of
children you remember the video before
right yeah and you see this one yeah
but how I'm saying if you go on Kendra
tea show
no it's ever I swear to God
I watched this is so live like every
night I I try to get on Kendra they
never let me on and I feel like I'm like
I feel like I would kill that show
but but no um no they literally are
always like that like soccer people that
call into that show oh okay I see so
it's uh I don't I don't think it's the
majority of women but I think there's a
large minority yeah that like a
substantial minority of women that are
delusional yeah I mean there's a large
minor there's a large amount of just
general delusional people I just feel
like this is not yeah that video in that
video and that TV show that is
specifically for those videos no that's
just videos that you've seen and I don't
think it represents loads of people so
here's the thing right yeah because I
don't I don't see men calling into shows
and demanding Victoria's Secret models
like I just don't see it I see women
demanding six-figure guys tall guys
whatever but I don't see girls or guys
calling into shows and saying I need a
model yeah you just get lost at he's
just like yeah she's okay not fat wait
that's enough no kids no question so
someone's calling into that show for a
man yes it's like a Imaging
okay so turn on your camera come on come
on
[Applause]
uh oh yeah give it a sec I'll I'll add
it on okay then okay oh that's fine all
right we'll watch the second part of it
and then I'll add my point okay let's
watch the second part cool
um from 10 15 10 15. yeah from 10 15. I
just
yeah I want to get your guys views on
this where is it
um
okay 10 15. yeah let's have a look
because you said was she calling that
shows for a man
we saw a guy who's that in the
background
who's that in the background speak you
could talk you've been talking to me the
whole time I told you I was that's the
guy you had sex with today foreign
so the guy you had sex with today is in
your house and you're on my show looking
for a new guy
I'm on my I'm on your show to tell you
that I'm single and if you know I find I
want my show to look for a new guy
because that's what this show is about
so so I'm on the show just to put myself
out there yes yeah you're on this you're
on the show to meet a new guy that's
what this show is about let's be clear
okay we're not gonna circle around the
fact of the show right you come on the
show to me whomever if you're into women
you're intimate so you want to meet a
guy
while you have the guy you slept with in
your house what kind of quality man you
think is going to hit you up
I'm just being honest I mean I mean I'm
being honest too what kind of quality
man you think is gonna hit you up I
don't know you tell me Kendra not one
okay
I mean I might wake up that a man will
hit you up that I want to have sex with
you but not a man that's going to take
you serious
not absolutely not there is no man
that's watching us right now a quality
man that's gonna hit you up and take you
serious with the guy you slept with this
morning in the background while you on
this show and if that's what you desired
and that's what you desire it's your
life but you're gonna have to own up to
the fact that you got a lot of stuff to
get together very trifling if you want
us and if you wanna if you want to
attract the trifling guy then so big
give them your Instagram page or the
Facebook page so I just
yeah yeah that's nice
yeah yeah it's just a bit cool yeah I
think that's hilarious I just hope she
has that same kind of comedic energy if
you know or let's say when she ends up
like being really alone
um and a lot older with like you know
boxed wine and cats you know but for me
I need to understand the psychology
that makes you think that you can call a
dating show yeah with the with the
person that you've just had sex with in
your house looking for another person
because I'll say this
I don't think a man would do that
I don't think a man would call a dating
show with the woman walking around naked
in the background that he's just had sex
with saying yeah I'm seeing I'm saying I
want to get another girl I don't think
men would do that I think they would do
that for their Lads they'd go be like
yeah I've got a girl but I'm you know
yeah
but like and then really going like
welcome dating shows because the thing
is going on a dating show doesn't always
mean you want to go on a date a lot of
the time you just want attention so do
you think she's actually looking for a
man I don't think she was I can I see
the feeling she was just trying to go
viral and yeah
just to see what's out there you know
what I would actually I would actually
magnify that to her on a bigger scale I
don't think a lot of girls actually want
to date I think they just want attention
as well you know and I'm not saying
there's anything wrong with that I'm
just saying it is what it is you know
like if you want to if you just want
attention that's fine but if you're
gonna masquerade that as like you want
to date and find a nice guy then do you
think that's a bit selfish when you have
kids to do that